foreign
[Music]
family people who like pink Pop-Tarts
welcome this is another Master Class my
first master class was on raising money
it was about how to create a killer
pitch deck that's the start of your
journey if you're an entrepreneur you're
trying to go raise money from investors
to uh to fund the company this is now
about the end of the company how do you
sell a company and Ben asked me to do a
master class he's like hey can you do
can you record a master class today your
boy's lazy so I'm repurposing a
presentation I gave uh three four years
ago at hustlecon I went on Google Drive
I found an old presentation I actually
didn't even look through it I'm just
going to do it live here uh sort of
improv style but I remember I remember
being on stage and giving this talk
about how to sell a company because I
just sold my first company and I
remember at the time being like I wish
there was some more content about this
because if you want to learn how to
manage people you're gonna there's tons
of books and you're gonna get practice
every day if you want to learn how to
grow revenue or sales there's tons of
books and you get practice every single
day when it comes to selling a company
there's very little content out there
that's at that I thought was any good
and you get very few reps you might sell
a company once every four years ten
years it's it's not a common thing that
you do and so um we're not you know if
you don't practice you're not very good
at anything so I learned something some
things during the process of selling my
companies and I'm going to share them
with you today
uh so let's see what I was thinking four
years ago the only thing I did was I
removed the hustlecon banner at the
bottom and I put a new logo there
because it said hustlecon 2019 I thought
that would not look so great so uh let's
jump in and hit the first slide here we
go
okay hey that's me
um look a little different nowadays not
too different here we go I still got the
headphones
we still got the headphones that we can
rock
um I've sold two companies now one to a
big company so when we sold a twitch
twitch owned by Amazon so selling a
company to Amazon was one way and then
milk road we sold two two private buyers
just like you know two dudes who uh were
independently wealthy from their
previous businesses and it was a it was
a totally different transaction so I'm
going to share some lessons from each
when I made this presentation I had only
sold Vivo so I added the milk Road one
just before I went live here
um but the rest of the presentation I
didn't add any lessons so let's see if
I've learned something the second time
I always start with this when it comes
to selling a company this is a this is a
picture of a foot and a dog and it is
the first picture ever posted on
Instagram Uh Kevin Systrom the founder
of Instagram he posted this uh right
when Instagram went live and
um you know today it's this like iconic
picture of like you know this is how it
all started and uh you know here's the
guy himself Kevin Systrom looks great
you know power pose got the white sneaks
and um if you're Kevin Systrom you know
you got a dozen employees you make a
billion dollars everybody loves you
right because you've built the hot thing
and everybody comes knocking at your
door right if you ask Kevin system how
do you sell your company he'd say well
you gotta create you know uh Sensational
product and then people will just come
and offer you a billion dollars right
like that would be his experience my
experience was very different we had
built a good not great business uh we
had built a good but early business and
we were trying to sell and so here's uh
what we experienced so if you're if
you're reading this or if you're
watching this
you are not Instagram and I think my
talk will be maybe a little bit more
applicable to you than than what uh you
might hear from the people that are on
the Forbes list because they're they
were in a totally different position of
Leverage and bargaining power than most
people are when they go to sell their
business
um this is you you've tried you've
pivoted you've hustled it's not working
or it's kind of working or it's working
but you're just tired you're ready to
move on um and this is a very common
thing entrepreneurs get to and um when
you're here it's okay to think uh you
know where should I go I've been there I
felt it myself and this advice I heard
all the time was great companies are
bought not sold that sounds pretty cool
it's a nice little fortune cookie but
remember you're not Instagram and so
great companies are bought not sold I
think that's true but most companies are
sold not bought that's my my contention
at least and that was my experience we
sold the companies more so than we just
immediately got bought because we were
just crushing it beyond belief like you
would like you see when uh you know
whatever huge companies get acquired
um here's a headline from when we got
bought this number is incorrect uh which
just shows you don't don't believe
everything you read in the media
um I don't know where they got that
exactly but uh yeah we we sold we sold
for you know eight figures but not uh
not like that uh you know once you and
and sales it's weird when people come up
with these numbers too because it's like
you get cash up front then we got the
signing bonus you get stock the stock
price changes you know it's all there's
all kinds of ways to to sort of like
manipulate
um sales numbers but
um when you get I let me let me go back
here when you got started
you thought this is gonna work and this
will be big if it works and I can do
this and I want to do this more than
anything else that's typically the
mindset of an entrepreneur when you
start and the reason I say this is
because the first thing when it comes to
selling your company is figure out do
you even want to sell that's why I
started here do you even want to sell
because when you're in this state of
mind no way you would sell why would you
sell this is going to work it's going to
be huge I could do this and I want to do
this more than anything else that's how
you should feel when you start a company
and then you have to check in and say
all right you're seven and try not to
check in on your most frustrated day but
you want to say uh do I still believe
this is going to work do I still believe
this will be big if it works do I still
believe I can do this and do I still
want to do this more than anything else
when we sold our first company we had
hit this you know all of them kind of
are true except for this will be big if
it works I thought we might have a
medium-sized exit the first time and
that's why I decided Well let's sell Now
versus
play this out for four years four more
years and hit a medium-sized exit yeah
it'll be multiples more than where we're
at today but
um it still requires four more years and
time is so precious with milk Road it
was more of the last one I want to do
this more than anything else it was
actually working and I thought it could
be big but
um my brain was wandering to new ideas
new things and I was loving doing the
podcast so much I just is this the one
thing I want to wake up and do every day
and focus on with laser focus yes or no
so these are the questions you got to
ask yourself say are these more true
today less true today or at the same as
when I started
and that gives you this takes to this
point point right when should you sell
so if you get a great offer cool
consider it if you don't believe in the
business anymore well maybe sell the
assets
because if you don't believe you're not
going to really take Massive Action you
don't take Massive Action you're not
going to get any results and then you'll
just reinforce your belief like see I I
knew it I knew it wouldn't work right so
belief is really really key
um and lastly the you know Common case
is you just don't want to run the
business anymore you prefer to exit
versus hire an operator and you just
you're ready to move on and do other
things so three moments where you might
sell
um who do you discuss with I just wanted
to put this up here for a second so you
know talk about it with yourself and
maybe some mentors but then yourself and
your partner is yourself and your
co-founders it's really a a lot of
conversations in your own head which is
why managing your own psychology during
a sales process is the number one most
important thing it's what helps you be
good in negotiation it's what helps you
uh get people across the line that's
what helps you
um you know stand up and operate every
day while you're also trying to sell the
company it's very difficult to do that
so managing your own psychology is
really important and then there's a note
about your investors in your team there
is a finesse you want to do with this
some people believe don't tell anybody
until the deals are done
some people say well no I want to be
transparent with my team
um for me I've always been on the be
transparent with your team but it does
have drawbacks people start to work a
little bit differently when they realize
oh we're gonna try to sell this thing
what does that mean for me should I be
looking for a job is this what happens
if we don't sell will I be rich what's
going to happen and so I think
discussing it with your investors or
your team is something to be very
careful about I probably aired too much
on the transparency side I if I would
gonna go play it back now I would only
discuss with my co-founders and I would
not talk to the team until the deal is
done
um and so you want to create a little
like communication table
um so your co-founders you want to tell
them ASAP uh you know hey it's time to
explore options I'm going to do X you
can help me by doing why
um investors you want to tell them and
say hey we're going to explore a sale
here's what I think it would look like
employees you might say hey we've been
approached we're considering it blah
blah here's the good news here's what it
means for you uh I wrote you know you
can put ASAP you can say this we're
going to do this when the deal closes
you can say that we're going to do this
when the deal's getting close to closing
you know you you want to decide your
timelines and create your communication
table
okay now to the fun Parts how do you
actually sell the dang thing so who's
who might buy you you want to break it
up into buckets of potential buyers
because you're really going to run a
sales process no matter who you are you
become a Salesman when it comes time uh
to do this so I would say there's four
potential buyers there's the Unicorn so
uh high growth companies that might want
to buy you
um to accelerate their growth
there's dying dinosaurs so you know
incumbents that might need to get fresh
blood fresh Tech fresh um you know fresh
energy fresh cash flow whatever it may
be
um there's your adjacent companies your
Json alligators uh this is like uh
what's that game Legend of the Hidden
Temple so yeah you got the adjacent
alligators they're they're next to you
uh they might be peers or uh competitors
that you merge with and the last one is
Talent Farms this is just go sell it to
Google and uh they just want Talent so
they don't care about your company or
your Market but they they just want
Engineers
um
you have to also know the different
roles who are you going to be talking to
so when you get bought
um the other side is going to have an
exec Champion so who's the one person
that really wants this deal to happen if
you can't identify that person ain't No
Deal gonna happen you should always know
who is the person that is pounding the
table on that side saying we got to do
this deal or hey come on let's figure
out a solution to that problem or dude
just let's bridge the gap let's come up
a little bit right you need to know who
is the champion on the other side
identify them and you're going to
nurture that relationship you got to
know who's the company router who's the
person in the middle that can get you to
the different people that need buy-in
usually in big companies will be Corp
Dev
um but in smaller companies you might
know who else it is maybe there's a
admin person or assistant just who are
you going to be able to reliably get
information from and two that's not
necessarily the key decision maker and
then you got your deal Doula so uh this
is using a childbirth metaphor
um so if you're trying to burp this baby
uh you know a do look who helps you you
know remember to breathe think about
this
um you know let's move to this position
it's gonna help hey we need to get water
here know your Doula is the one helping
you through this often you know
painful but wonderful uh you know um
process and so I like to find my dealers
these are one or two people who have
done M A before
um in my you know they're in my corner I
can trust them that they'll be keep
everything confidential and I'm gonna
bug the hell out of them I'm gonna you
know these are people that I was texting
and saying uh hey I'm gonna say this
back you know is that too desperate no
no okay let me you know wordsmithing it
like I'm a you know seventh grade girl
trying to figure out do they like me do
they not like me how do I phrase this in
a way that demonstrates strength without
pushing too far your deal duelist will
help with that
uh for those who love one of the
greatest shows on Earth this is the
Dennis system so I'm going to take you
through the Dennis system of how to how
to sell your company so
stage one the D demonstrate values so
why do companies buy companies there are
financial reasons and then there are
strategic reasons so financial reasons
obvious you're crushing it you're making
tons of money they want your ebitda they
want your Revenue uh pretty
straightforward if you have it many
people don't so who buys companies when
there's strategic reasons well here's
six strategic reasons
um the CEO finds it interesting that's
the first one that is surprising uh how
far that goes CEO's got a pet project
CEO has got an itch to scratch awesome
if you're so lucky to have that
fantastic number two there's a new
executive or an executive gets a
promotion and they need to demonstrate
big moves as a signal so they're they're
they're on the way out or they're on the
way in and they're looking for for some
kind of big move some big big thing to
do as a signal that's good for you when
that happens number three they're trying
to catch up to a surging competitor
um you know this is Adobe trying to
catch up with you know using figma to
catch up this is uh there are many
examples of this along the way Synergy
one plus one equals three this is Uber
with DD in China so that they don't keep
competing each other driving costs up
they say hey why don't we merge into one
entity and then we own a monopoly we can
cut cost actually we can raise prices
um so one plus one could equal three in
this case
um they're afraid of you this is
Facebook buying Instagram you know you
do what they do but better Instagram was
better at sharing photos than Facebook
and uh okay you're gonna get a strategic
premium when that when that's the case
and the last one is you have unique
talent so you might have computer vision
phds and they're having trouble finding
that talent in mass and it's actually
cheaper to acquire you and get the
talent as a bundle that's proven to work
together versus going through a long
slow recruiting process and so it's
important to figure out for every
potential buyer what what might be the
reasons that the that that they will
they will buy you
um
Next Step e engage physically so who do
you actually reach out to what do you
saying what's the goal
um you know you can reach out to a
number of folks University Executives
just go meet somebody who's
um at the company Corp Dev their job is
to meet companies that might be
interesting to acquire
um investors might make introductions
you know when we were selling we went to
uh I went to an investor who was an
investor in Discord and I said hey we
got this thing Discord I want to buy it
he said let me email the CEO CEO gets an
email from their biggest investor
they're going to take it seriously and
then all of a sudden I'm you know next
day I'm in a meeting with the CEO and
I'm pitching why this why one plus one
could equal three
um there's also advisors
and what do you say you know you say hey
I want to discuss a partnership on how
we might be able to work together intent
right like that's discuss a partnership
is the best way to kind of open the door
the more aggressive way which I've done
also is hey we got an offer you know
we're considering our next steps maybe
we're going to raise money we or we have
an acquisition offer uh we'd love to
talk to you before we just go and make a
decision and they say oh yeah yeah come
talk to us first don't just don't just
do it without you know we want to we
want to take a peek under the hood we
want to know our options before we get
in your goal here is just to get an
in-person meeting and so
um you know use these two frames in
order to get an in-person meeting now
what do you do if you don't know them
well you got to reach out you got to
reach out cold ideally you've been
building a relationship over time this
is the smart way to do it is you meet
people in The Company You Keep Them
posted with light updates they see you
they know you they see you at an
industry event so that when the time
comes you can do this you're not an
absolute stranger approaching them but
I've done it as a stranger too usually
when I'm a stranger Corp Dev is the
easiest way to go
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
[Music]
um next and nurture dependence I'm
covering some of the words here but you
want lust not love lust is going to get
is a high burst immediate like oh I see
that it's like greed it's like oh I want
something out of this your goal is to
tap into emotions and when I say this
it's about Clarity not trickery you're
not going to manipulate anybody into
buying your company what you can do is
frame what you're doing in a way that is
maximally appealing to them something
that Taps into their desires their
dreams their emotions their pain points
and you need to
trim the fat of your story so that you
are the answer to that problem
um I'll give you an example when we sold
to Twitch
I had met in terms of engage physically
I gone I'd gone through Corp Dev Corp
devil got me a meeting with the CEO the
next day and I said all right well I
don't know what to I don't know how to
frame what we're doing to the CEO
but I had met a guy on a boat in
Australia of all places who worked at
twitch who's an exec I said I gotta hit
that guy up so I hit him up I said hey
can I get a beer with you today say oh
yeah yeah sure let's do it I said I got
a meeting with the CEO tomorrow I don't
know how to navigate it you know the guy
can I just gonna be with you just to get
you down up so I go get a beer with him
and I say uh you know here's
um you know what's he like what's he you
know what what should I expect blah blah
blah and then I said
tell me what are the top like three when
you're in these exec meetings you're you
know you're you're at the highest level
I'm stroking the ego you're you're I
know you're in the room when they're
making the big decision so what are the
top three priorities like what do y'all
really care about is it profitability is
it revenue is it growth where what are
the top of your priorities I think he'll
say them I said okay I said which one of
those is like stuck which one of those
needs a solution because like sometimes
you already have a solution in mind you
love that solution you don't want to
interrupt it but which one is still we
don't really love our plan here it feels
the weakest and needs some bolstering
and then he told me hey we have this
thing and actually everybody's pretty
bullish on it but we don't have the
right team and we don't want the tech to
do it and the guy we have he's not good
with tech so it's gonna be a problem oh
say less so then when I go into the
meeting the next day I say
we're great at doing this one thing and
I'm a great leader and I know Tech and
we have the team that we have the tech
already built and I have the team that
can that built it and so now I packaged
my story as how I am the solution to
their problem versus what most people do
is they come in as a startup and say
here's what we do here's why we're great
you know here's this other feature we
have here's this feature we have and oh
this guy says this they're all over the
place and it's like all right good for
you but that doesn't tell me why I want
you so it's a sales pitch you gotta
package yourself as the solution to
their problem
um another way to say this you need to
find their pain offer a cure
um you know other questions that might
be helpful what initiative has the most
juice or momentum or buy-in right now
you want to buy in is like the best word
with corporations what has all what has
all the the exact buy-in right now oh
they're all bought into this idea uh
what are the fires that he's putting out
who's on the chopping block
um what company are you guys most afraid
of
um if I only had 20 minutes in front of
your CEO what part of what we're doing
do you think he'd be most interested in
talking about
um and then you also want to suss out
who's the decision maker so hey right
now we're talking to this guy is he the
decision maker or who should we be
talking to oh no no his boss is boss is
the guy
um then you want to talk down talk to
this is a little Pro tip talk to
Founders who have been acquired by the
same company before so go to them say
hey
you acquired three years ago four years
ago whatever what was it like how did
the process go were the timelines that
they told you real or fake was the when
they said this is the most we could do
was that real or fake um did they try to
retrade the deal later or not
um what what was your experience with
the CEO was he really into it was he is
he more reserved what did what did that
mean you're trying to get a bunch of
Intel and hey this is founder to founder
from somebody who uh you know has done
it before ideally who's left the company
now uh I got a ton of great Intel on
this
okay here's another
this is just a classic move when we did
it you want to do the work for them so
what a lot of people do is they say
here's here's what we do
then they sit there and they pray I hope
they understand it I hope they get it I
hope they like it
no true that you take matters into your
own hands so you basically say
hey I wrote up a one-pager that explains
where I think this makes a lot of sense
strategically for you guys because if
we're going to do this then um you know
I want to make sure you know I thought
about this from your perspective and
what what this would look like once we
join
um you know I did some crazy things so
basically on the technical side I had
our team write a technical one-page
here's all the stuff we built how long
it would take for anybody to build it
what's our special sauce
um so that they could just see man
buying this is going to save us so much
time look at all these assets they
already have uh here's the talent here's
my I've made our team a present like
into a presentation of like here's all
the talent we have what they've done
before make it really easy for them it's
a dating profile do I want to swipe
right or left on these people
um and then I the thing I wrote a letter
from the CEO I said I said um
I think this deal makes a lot of sense
and I wanted to write that out into a
memo I know you guys have this memo
writing culture like Amazon has this
thing like you write six page memos for
all your strategies so I took a stab I
wrote One um you know I obviously I
don't know some of the internal things
so I you know I took guesses they're
they're in blue you can see the guesses
but um yeah I wanted to put my Logic on
paper because I don't want to do this if
this doesn't make sense right you're not
saying please please buy me you're
saying I'm trying to figure out does
this make sense for both of us it's a
two-way street and so in order to do
that I wrote something to give myself
Clarity I thought you'd like to see it
and so um I actually wrote for one of
the Acquisitions I said this is how I
would announce this deal to the to the
company to the team to your exact team
and the rest of the employees
and I just wrote a really persuasive
argument of like we bought this company
here's why here's why this was a good
idea here's how here awesome this is
going to be here's the how this solves
one of our problems uh I'm so excited
about this acquisition and like in doing
so again I made it easy somebody told me
this one of my deal duels he goes you
need to turn your company into a giant
buy button like a like Amazon one-click
checkout so that means make it easy to
understand what you do make it easy for
them to understand your team your
technicals your your Strat how you
strategically align and last thing you
get your get all your financials in like
very clean proper uh you know data room
so that
there's no friction in trying to buy
your company
last one neglect emotionally the Dennis
Reynolds special so you need to find
another partner you need to go cold all
right you don't want to be all in hot on
one partner that is not how you get the
best deal so you need to find multiple
partners at the same time you need to be
negotiating these in parallel you don't
do one at a time you you start the
process you're now doing running you
know you're starting conversations with
10 folks that wants 20 Folks at once
you're narrowing it down you're trying
to get multiple offers in the same week
so that you could tell them hey we got
another offer
um sometimes you go cold a little bit
make them sweat uh not too long don't
push it but uh it's not a bad thing I
also leave breadcrumbs I don't know if
this made a difference or not but I
would like
check in on my Instagram story like I'm
in Seattle
oh cool I've never been to the office to
this cool office before and like they
know they're like oh he's at Microsoft
he's at Facebook where is he he's
talking he's talking to our competitors
um so you know I don't know if that
works but it amused me at the least it
made me feel like I was doing some some
James Bond
all right last one Inspire hope this is
where you go back to me say look we got
other options but we want you can you
make that happen can you get your deal
can you get your offer a little stronger
here here and here and it's time
sensitive look like we have this other
offer on the table they're not going to
sit around and wait
um so if you can get us something we can
we would like to work with you we think
you are the best fit but obviously you
know Bird in Hand this is a really good
offer and you know I don't want to blow
it for my team by by sitting here hoping
you guys come around
um you know you need to to use the The
Leverage from one deal to get a better
deal
and then you sell entirely so you need
to do the you have your due diligence
stuff ready you need to make sure that
the closing terms are clean you need to
get a good lawyer and a good accountant
don't and don't burn Bridges because
deals fall through and you may need to
go back so make sure you communicate
properly even when you say no to people
um and uh do everything with with sort
of integrity and Grace because uh many
times deals have fallen through we need
to go back when we sold the milk Road it
was a somebody we had rejected last
minute
but we didn't burn the bridge and they
didn't burn the bridge and we came back
you know later and we said hey still
interested and they sure were and there
you go the advice I got here was uh
before my deal Doula was this is when
you need to Sprint the hardest so
normally an entrepreneur gets a term
sheet it's like they want to relax
finally look at this the big number I'm
Gonna Be Rich this is awesome
and they take a moment to relax you
can't relax here this is where you
sprint the hardest to close you cancel
everything else you just spend all day
following up with lawyers data room uh
your accountant making sure that all
your ducks are in a row solving any
problems uh along the way
and lastly celebrate make sure you
celebrate uh very often the whole
process is so stressful that the the
main feeling is just relief I think
that's common but you want to let that
relief subside and then have the joy and
the The Pride that you you did something
kind of amazing and so uh I don't know
if I have any other slides left okay
remember some some tips here
the great advice I got birds fly fish
swim and deals for all through that's
what they do just remember deals fall
through that is completely normal for
them
um you can't get emotionally too high
too low the second deal momentum is
everything if you have a conversation
going the speed with which you follow up
and you get them the materials and you
you move forward is everything momentum
is everything when it comes to deal
making and last thing one choice is no
choice if you only have one person that
could buy you one company that's gonna
buy you you have essentially zero people
that will buy you have zero leverage so
you need to have multiple choices one
choice is no choice
all right that's it
um that's the master class let me know
what you thought about that one drop
comments um on YouTube so that's where I
read them so go to go to YouTube my
first million hit the thumbs up if you
like this subscribe to the channel where
over 200 000 subscribers now that's
amazing if you guys like these I'll do
more of these uh they're not easy to do
these master classes right like and it
ain't easy to drop these kinds of bombs
but if you guys like it I will make an
effort and I will try to do more of
these uh until I'm all out of knowledge
and um and then I'll then I'll stop and
just go retire so let me know if these
are worth doing and uh your compliments
fuel me to do more all right I'm out of
here
[Music]
thank you